Catherine Grandin chairman of baber
District Council and I will be chairing
the meeting today
may I first of all remind you of some
domestic Arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs and meet on the Ipswich
Town Football Club cleaning pick
do not re-enter the building until
you're told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and we'll be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May recalled film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the Press are not lawfully
excluded
counselors before I move to the gender
can I request that all counselors use
their microphones when speaking and make
all requests to speak through the chair
I'll now move on to the agenda
item one apologies for absence
thank you chair I have received
apologies from council's melvizzi
carpondale Creswell Holt Gould Huron and
Norman
thank you
two Declaration of Interest by
councilors
councilor beer
councilor Newman sends his
thank you councilor We'll add that to
the list
in accordance with delegated authority
the monitoring officer has granted
dispensations to all members in respect
of the 23 stroke 24 budget papers
other than that do we have any other
declarations
thank you
item three
BC
2239 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 23rd of January 2023
for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
okay thank you could I have a proposer
please Simon Barrett Council Simon
Barrett can I have a seconder please
councilor Fraser thank you
we're going to do this by show of hands
could I ask all those in favor to raise
their hands please
thank you that is carried
item four BC
2240 announcements from the chairman and
leader
so first of all I refer you to paper
bc2240 for noting
and then I just wanted to say a few
words of thanks to everyone who attended
the Chairman's fundraising dinner on the
28th of January at Royal Hospital School
thank you very much to all of those who
attended and thank you also to all of
those who bought raffle tickets
um for the event
um and I'd just like to announce that we
raised
of tremendous amount of money for the
blossom appeal which is raising money
for the new Breast Care Center at
Ipswich Hospital
in one night we managed to raise eleven
thousand one hundred and thirty six
pounds
which I understand is a record
um for a chairman of this Council I'd
like to thank you all for your support
[Applause]
I would now like to invite councilwor to
make his announcements thank you
councilor Ward thank you Jim
last Friday we held the last public
Suffolk public sector leaders meeting
before the elections in May so I thought
it'd be good an opportune moment to
update you on what we have been doing
apart from agreeing important financial
support for the collaborative
communities board to support food
networks across the county and for the
housing board to provide supported
living training and to get additional
support for tackling rough sleeping at
the meeting last week we also launched
our latest report summarizing all that
we have achieved over the past three
years with the pooled business rates
funding at our disposal
so bear with me a bit it's the longest
list but um it's quite informative
we've given 2.35 million pounds to
support businesses at and the County's
post covering recovery probe post
covered recovery program which 1.4
million has been put into the Suffolk
inclusive growth investment fund and
this has supported several projects in
labor virtual High Street innovate local
and also the Innovation labs in Sudbury
1.35 million has been given to tackled
county lines and criminal exploitation
1.5 million to deliver the Suffolk
climate emergency plan
756 000 to improve the Energy Efficiency
of homes in the county
an additional 80 000 pounds has been
given to screen suffer following the
setup support we gave in 2016.
500 000 pounds so the county councils
get Suffolk reading initiative
five hundred thousand pounds for the
collaborative communities board and four
hundred thousand pounds for Suffolk
Family Focus for preventative work to
support vulnerable people in the county
two hundred thousand pounds has been
given to the integrated care Academy to
support young people and their Mental
Health
one million pounds for the local welfare
assistance service to support residents
facing financial hardship
and we've also earmarked a million
pounds for Hawley Junction another
million pounds for the housing board and
375 000 pounds has been near marked for
the resources and waste strategy
in addition there was initial support
for Suffolk office of data analytics
when it was set up in 2018 which is now
well respected and much used source of
data analytics and insight Services used
by public sector and organizations in
the county
so in total since it's an Inception in
2013 spsl has received 23.9 million
pounds of pool business rates funding of
which 21.4 million pounds has been spent
or committed
and all this demonstrates that we can
achieve so much when we come together
and work as a system across the county
it bodes well for the Devolution deal
that has been agreed with government
collaboration between councils is
increasingly the only way we can tackle
the larger issues that our residents
face
no council can work in isolation no
matter what some may think here
so finally the other thing I just wanted
to report on and and it's following up
talking about the spsl end of term
report just another shout out for our
own end of term report
just another reminder to let you all
know so you can all let your Parish
councils know and also Community groups
and residents that our end of term
report is available it's available
online and if not people can see it in
the customer access points in Sudbury
and Hadley it's full of interesting and
useful information about all the good
things we've been able to achieve over
the past four years thank you Jim
bank accounts award
item five to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with Council
procedure rules
thank you chair none received
thank you
item six questions by the public in
accordance with Council procedure rules
I refer you to the question in the
tabled papers and I would like to invite
Mr Ferguson to ask his question
to Ferguson
thank you madam chairman
my question is to the cabinet member for
finance assets and Investments
a council meeting on Thursday the 6th of
October last year
I asked the cabinet member of Finance
assets and Investments for a copy of the
risk assessment of gipping
construction's ability to complete the
redevelopments of the old Baywood
District Council officers at coastline
and one of the reasons that I gave her
this request was my concern about
gipping's limited experience with
working on listed buildings and part of
the old Council headquarters of course
is listed
in his response councilor Busby refused
to let me see that risk assessment
and baby District Council also refused
to provide it when I substantly
submitted a freedom of information
request
however in his reply to my question on
6th of October
council boss me told me that babe of
growth limited would ensure completion
of the project on time and on cost
through robust management of a contract
and he went on to say that April 2024
had been set as the completion date
also in response to a question from
councilor Dawson who is the ward member
for Hadley North and where uh course
Lane sets a question to the chief
executive
and this is with regards to the time
frame of the final impact of delays in
the development work the chief executive
responded as follows
the work on site has been progressing
well and in line with the project with
the projected programs
he went on to say there are currently no
significant delays to the program
and therefore the financial implications
are that there is some cost to the
redesigned work but this is allowed for
within the project contingencies
in the context of those assurances
we now know that works stopped on this
project at the end of November last year
it is now and as of today and I drove
past it today just to double check
I can update you as of this afternoon
work has still not restarted restarted
and so it is three months
that that project has now been in
lockdown there's nothing going on there
so my question uh Council Busby is
against that background are you still
reporting that the corks Lane
Redevelopment will be delivered on time
and on cost
and will it be completed by April 2024.
if not
what has changed since you've provided
those assurances on the 6th of October
and what are the potential implications
on the 2023-2024
Baywood District Council budget
forecasts
thank you Mr Ferguson I would now like
to invite councilor Busby to respond
however the Redevelopment of the former
HQ at Hadley is a complex project due to
the listed buildings and unique nature
of the existing buildings on site the
complex nature of this Redevelopment was
anticipated and allowed for within
project contingencies it was expected
that there would be a need to make
adaptations to the program as Works
progressed on-site and additional
Heritage aspects were uncovered whilst
work has slowed down on site
considerable technical work is still
underway and we anticipate works on site
accelerating in March labor growth are
still reporting this project to be on
budget and on time however it should be
noted that we're still at the very early
stages of this development
thank you councilor Busby Mr Ferguson
would you like to ask a supplementary
question
well I'd like to make an observation
first if I may uh Madam chairman
he's linked in with the response that
I've just had
which quite frankly I find
less than informative and rather
disappointing in the context of the
reality
that it has now been shut down for three
months which was clearly never planned
but if I can put that to one side
my question Madam chairman is can we be
assured to do and I'm now talking in
terms of the residents of Hadley in
particular because this question is
being asked all the time can I ask that
we be assured to be given updates in the
context of what's going on with this
program in terms of further developments
starts to impact on the costs of it
keep you up to date on what's going on
specifically especially with the cost
however as I said it's at an early stage
we anticipated that there would be
issues and there have been fortunately
these occurred during the winter period
during Christmas and the new year when
work on site would not have been
happening anyway so we haven't lost
three months and work has been going on
the problems were caused by ground
conditions discovered which affected the
car Park area
as well as Heritage assets uncovered in
the early part of the on-site works so
we've had to do additional design work
to sort this out and then this has to be
signed off by the statutory authorities
but work will start and proceed at a
pace very soon
moving on with the agenda item seven
questions by counselors in accordance
with Council procedure rules
I refer you to the questions in the
table papers and I'd like to invite
councilor Lindsay to ask his first
question counselor Lindsay
was born a Cabinet member for housing
what triggered the in-depth review into
Building Services thanks
again Osborne
chairman thank you for your question
councilor Lindsay
there are a number of things that
triggered the ReUse there have been
several changes for registered housing
providers and these include the building
safety act changes to the fire safety
order
social housing white paper and new
regulation by the regulator of social
housing which is new to stockholding
councils
this and the pandemic led us to accept
the need to review the impact of the in
the end pandemic and recover from it
also we recognize that some of the
previous changes hadn't achieved the
long-term impact that we had hoped for
so we wanted to do a route and Branch
review to understand the issues and
develop sustainable long-term Solutions
fully and completely
as our director of housing has said many
times we are not in a unique position
unfortunately many other councils are in
a similar if not worse position
thank you councilor Osborne Council
Lindsay have got supplementary question
please chair
um
elaborate a bit on what the previous
changes were that hadn't
judge impact
we had hoped for thanks
sorry could you repeat that please yeah
um you said in your answer that uh some
of the
the amongst the reasons for for
triggering the review
um does all the legislative changes but
they're also
um some of the previous changes hadn't
achieved the impact we had hoped for
what what do you mean by that thanks
did you want to respond councilor
Osborne
writer can do it further by an email
um I think
um obviously we've had issues with
materials that we hadn't visualized
would happen so that has had a huge
impact
staffing issues through sickness covered
and also going into the private sector
as well so these were things that we
should have envisaged but didn't and it
has impacted on where we are I think the
important thing is to not look back
but to look forward and to be assured
that changes are going to happen
improvements are going to happen and
I've been standing here and I've said
that for a long time but I am so much
more confident now that this is going to
be the fact so I think rather than
backwards let's look forwards and
hopefully the new Administration will
start to see improvements in a very
short period of time
thank you councilor Osborne Council
Lindsay had a second question
yes thank you chair and thank you for
your previous answers again
amazing
um is this review looking at reasons for
the backlog in housing repair
work and whether outside contractors are
completing work in a
minute would you like to respond to
councilors yeah
I'll take this question in two parts if
I may which the first one is the review
looking at reasons for the backlog in
housing repair work
the review is looking at all areas
including the backlogging repairs cost
and quality and that's as I said in my
in the first question that is what
triggered the review didn't seem to be
working so now we need to look at why it
wasn't working and address that issue
thank you Council Osborne did you have a
supplementary councilor Lindsay oh I'm
sorry did you not finished
yeah are outside contractors completing
work properly we do have some concerns
with the performance of some of our
contractors and we are doing a piece of
work to improve performance and ensure
that we get good value for money
great thank you so did you have a
supplementary councilor Lindsay
please thank you um
are we getting a grip on the backlog now
is it reducing or is it increasing or
what
cancer Osborne did you want to respond
yeah it's not good news we have we
currently have
1845 outstanding repairs and the problem
is as fast as we catch up try to catch
up on those we've got new repairs coming
in so it's a really difficult situation
we need to look at and that's what the
review will look at why the backlog
isn't actually getting less and it's in
some respects
is um the operatives are working really
hard to reduce those
um against some really challenges again
it's materials again it's lack of some
skilled Workforce but it's an area
that's obviously being looked at as part
of the review I hope that answers your
question
thank you councilor Osborne
item eight paper BC 2241
general fund budget
2023-24 and four-year Outlook
I would like to invite councilor Busby
to introduce this item and to to move
the recommendations in the report
councilor Busby
well what a 12 months it's been
especially it can't be a great backdrop
when your finances seem to be under the
control of Mr Putin housing developers
and a government that is completely
devoid of solutions and any
understanding of Public Services
and unfortunately the next 12 months
look like being much of the same making
this a difficult budget
the surge in inflation and the need to
offer competitive salaries means that
net service expenditure is up 19 percent
2.4 million and interest charges up from
near zero to four percent 1.2 million
find an extra
3.6 million pounds when the government
restricts an increase in council tax to
2.99 that delivers 200 000 pounds is a
challenge and it's a credit to the hard
work of the finance team and all of the
service managers that we've managed in
it may seem strange to some that two
councils of similar size who share the
same staff the same building and largely
the same objectives and policies can
have such wildly different Financial
positions
the main answer is an extra 6.6 million
of new homes bonus
over the 12 years it's just been
operating mid Suffolk has received 18.4
million compared to baber's 11.8
is it right that a council's finances
can be so influenced by developers and
the speed that they want to build out
and at the 11th Hour the government
announces that it will fund us for the
potential loss of a million pounds on
business rates and we managed to find
through savings and the use of reserves
of balance
however while cycling presented balanced
budget for you today we are still facing
considerable Financial challenges going
forward
some things many things need to change
in local government financing but in the
meantime I move the recommendations in
three and ask for a second thank you
Council Busby Council award you'd like
to be seconder thank you
we'll now move to questions
counselors may ask as many questions as
they wish however they must be relevant
to the subject under discussion and must
be a question
would anyone like to open the questions
the questions
oh councilor beer
thank you madam chairman I'll start with
all role I've got a question to the
cabinet member on page 30 million
if we come halfway down Leisure
contracts Kim Fisher Leicester sent to
planned maintenance
yeah yep
that's all right I'll wait
yep
um plant maintenance there
um you're raising
another hundred thousand pounds because
up until
uh end of March 23 641
000 uh is there
um why do you need to raise another
hundred thousand when
um and I have letters here from members
of the public regarding the Kingfisher
Leisure Center Rambo epicross Leisure
where they complain and about the health
suite at the Kingfisher pool the jacuzzi
of the sauna
um they require new pumps uh the sauna
has been closed for a central pairs been
told by members of staff at the
Kingfisher that they're waiting funded
from yourselves we've got 641 000 there
um
and therefore cannot provide any idea
when the health Suite will be open be
able to reopen despite the fact that
myself and and the rest of the members
of the king official letter seem to pay
the same amount of money
when the facility is not open or
adequate
um I could go on there's lots of
problems there the bikes the monitors
the gym
there really does seem to be a lack of
um understanding there
as like with a lot of these things
there's no one taken responsibility
uh
that the Bucks got to stop somewhere and
if it's not with them then it'll come
forward it's going to stop with you
because you're asking for more money to
provide these things and a letter from
Abby croft's Leisure sauna and Spa blah
blah blah
um the spa was just waiting for a part
to arrive once fitted will be returned
to use we estimate this will take place
in early February
but we will update you as and when we
have a confirmed day this was sent out
in January no date put on it I mean
that's poor in itself
um no body that you can really contact
your sincerely it does give a name I
won't give her that you won't of these
unfortunately after a lot of
Investigations that the Saun was beyond
useful life and cannot be fixed and will
remain out of action until further
notice and it goes on to say that all of
this yes well it's coming to it it's
you're wanting another hundred thousand
pounds but you're not delivering on
what's already there and
um the public there are upset about it
um and there is nobody we can complain
to or speak to or try to speak on the
phone or contact so it's a poor service
Mr chairman can you help
Mr cabinet then but not yet
uh I agree
I think yeah you're right
um I guess one of the reasons that we've
not done I think he's not we've not been
able to have the parts uh they've not
been able to get them but we have got it
down and the yeah the key is that we do
spend the 641 plus the additional
hundred and I guess the additional 100
is there because of the additional work
that needs to be done
um yeah I take it on board that we need
to get these problems sorted out uh it's
got it in the budget for next year let's
sort it
thank you Council Busby
anyone else with a question
okay
councilor Hinton
thank you madam chairman um that's a
quick one really I noticed from the
general fund summary on page 21. that uh
employees the cost of employees goes
from 9.9 Million last year
to 11.6 million for the coming Financial
year what are the numbers of employees
involved in that are the employee
numbers increasing or are they
decreasing are there loads of vacancies
how do we justify spending another 1.6
million
councilman did you want to answer that
or did you want an officer to answer
this
thank you for your question
um yeah if you have a look at the um
table two on the next page you'll see
that 1.9 million of that increase is
actually related to pay award increments
and the pay review so it's not
necessarily that we're growing our
establishment it's more that we are
having to pay more for the cost of
living for our staff as well so that's
the largest largest chunk of that
uh did you have another question uh
supplementary yes all right so we're
painting them a lot more
um but how many staff have we got
because I know that the start the
workforce is split work wise between
mid-suffolk and us and and baber how
many total staff are we accountable for
oh tooth executive will answer this
question thank you if you bear with me
I'll find the the current figures
because as you appreciate it will change
on a daily basis members will know that
I on an annual basis provided all member
briefing about all things Staffing both
in terms of the head count and the uh
full-time equivalent numbers so that
you've got that kind of information
regularly available to you
um but if you bear with me I'll see if I
can find the details and can certainly
email around the current figures during
the course of the meeting uh but as
Melissa Evans already alluded to the
main uh impact financially is a result
of the pay award last year that pay
award last year defined by uh centrally
so not within our gift was
1925 pounds per person and that's what
you see playing through into the numbers
uh before you today for last year's
inflation pay award that worked out
obviously a lot lower than the actual
rate of inflation
thank you councilor beer
thank you
um could you please tell me how much
um
does it cost us the wages is it still
roughly 85 percent Uh custom for wages
out of our Capital all the money that we
get in
so I understand where they get the 85
from I I was told some time ago that uh
the wages bill was roughly 85 percent
now is that correct or not
and if it's not can you give us the
correct figure yeah I don't recognize
that
Melissa would you like to answer this
question please
yeah um it's not 85
um I think it might help you to see if
you look on chart four on page 23 you
can see the total of our employee costs
um as a gross amount for our total
expenditure so you can see that it's
almost I would say it's probably about
half of our costs is on employee costs
that does include pension on cost as
well so it's not just what we're paying
our staff it's our cost to the council
for the pension as well employers
national insurance tax as well on top of
that so that's the total cost as well as
car allowances in
could I have a what I'm asking for is
the percentage of all that added
together what has it costed the taxpayer
in their payment every payment they're
paying how much of that is going on
wages whether it's with pensions
and everything
that's not difficult
certainly take that away and calculate
that for you I don't want to do a quick
calculation and quote wrong so I can
certainly give you that calculation if
you can give it to us before we get to
the vote and of the budget
be helpful thank you
councilor Melanie Barrett
thank you chair
um my question is about the assumptions
that would be made in the budget about
the staff course in the in the in the
next year on page 29 Table Six
um the employee costs are you're
anticipating a pay Award of two percent
is that realistic next year can given
that the we know that the pressures that
employers are are facing and sometimes
submitting to in public sector bodies
unionized environments typically getting
more than that
so I don't know whether why you've
arrived at two percent is that just
because it's a historic figure and you
think that that may well be be
sufficient
can anyone answer that
suppose Peter do you want to answer that
or an officer well I it may not be
sufficient
Dart anyway where it'll end up I don't
know but we it'll be the nationally
agreed figure councilor Busby um the
chief executive will speak now
I was going to say something German
thank you but I'll make you throw the
question in the direction of Miss Evans
I'll tell you what I think it says and
I'll get to tell if I'm right or wrong
so I don't think it's two percent I
think it's four percent that we've
assumed within the budget in terms of
pay inflation but that's I'm posing that
question in that direction
so I guess you were correct for next
year it's four percent but actually for
the next three years we're forecasting
two percent but obviously we had to we
had to forecast something we don't know
what's going to happen after next year
with inflation so we went for two
percent which is what previously we've
always gone with but for next year it's
four percent in the budget
and Melissa have you
um provided a response as well to the
your previous question if I have yet
I've just messaged Jan so she's got that
[Music]
0.8 percent
so so the response from Melissa is 50.8
percent
50.8
um
so yes yes thank you
um cancer Sean Dawson
you've got a supplementary Council
Barrett yes
um so I don't want to misunderstand this
you've said four percent on table twin
on table six on on page 29 it says pay
award two percent
can you clarify yep so that's from 24 25
25 26 and 26 27 years
2026-27 so it's it's the next three
years after the budget we're about to
set for next year so it's four percent
for twenty twenty three twenty four and
then two percent for the next three
years after that
thank you
um councilor Sean Dawson
um yes I'm just wondering with the all
these increased costs in the budget
um can you confirm that this will be
covering the cost of um parking
because this is obviously we're not
going to be having increased budget and
parking because that's not what we'll be
expecting
that's supposed to be uh yes it will
cover the cost of parking it's included
in the budget as it always has been
I'm delighted to hear that so there'll
be no implementation of car parking fees
after the election
you said that I didn't and we're down to
the next Council to decide on that
Council Alistair McCraw
thank you Chad um with regard to
councilor Beer's question about Staffing
costs I just note analysis for
information as much as uh asking a
question page 23 chart 4 does show a
graph with expenditure by type excluding
housing benefits
taken separately but it shows that
employment employees costing
11.613 million I think that's probably
that roughly describes 50 percent of
that pie chart and I hope that will help
inform the debate
thank you councilor councilor Simon
Barrett
can you use your microphone please
I think we
we surely would be separate so that
includes all extensions including the
housing HRA account doesn't it not
so that's purely just the general fund
it doesn't take into account wages that
go into the
into the other budget
right
councilor Lindsay
one was on
page
[Music]
um
regarding ICT costs
there's a 409 000 in there for contracts
and I think in pressures it says there's
an increase of 40 000 in contract costs
um so the ICT is becoming a very large
line item in expenditure
um
could someone explain
what that's all about why the extra
costs um
and
on page the following page
uh 66
we've got two items involving climate
change
it would be nice to I don't quite
understand why there's two separate
items both with climate change in
um Can can someone give us a breakdown
of what the total expenditure on climate
change is as opposed to economic growth
because to a very definitely not the
same thing
in fact I would argue they're opposite
things but
it'd be good to have a breakdown of what
the expenditure on climate change is
alone thank you
not supposed to be did you want to
answer that or did you want an officer
to take that
I couldn't ask that off the top of my
head I'll have to seek professional
advice oh could you stand please
I'll keep acceptable so I'm happy to
take the latter one um the fact that you
appears twice is because the first one's
the heading
um so it's the same numbers on the two
lines simply because one is a summary
but where there's only one Line's worth
of detail it means you see it twice um
so you can take either of those but
those are the numbers in terms of the
first question I'd defer to Miller
sirens
thank you
um I probably would prefer to give you a
more detailed written answer but what I
would say is that's the cost of all of
the council's software excluding the HRA
so that's all of the software that the
councils use
um software is quite expensive and
obviously the increase is linked to
inflation rate so about 10 on that would
be about 40K increase on that cost so
but I'm happy to provide a breakdown of
what's in there if you would
thank you
Council Ward
sorry councilman I was just going to say
I I may be wrong but I think he probably
includes the cost of the new Finance
um I.T system that hopefully will be in
place by
the summer
the Busby Council award
a question
um well actually it's just to provide a
bit of further clarification
just want um quickly for councilor
Lindsay the reason why climate change is
under on that table on that page is
simply because
um the same director is responsible for
the economic growth and the climate
change services so
uh that those two are kept together in
in that table although climate change is
itemized separately I just wanted to um
clarify some points about the the staff
percentage costs chart four shows the
all of the expenditure of of the council
um and itemizes it by different
expenditure type you'll see there that
the staff expenditure is 51 of the total
now I know uh councilor beer was trying
to relate that to the money we get in
which is a combination of funding and
business rates council tax Government
funding plus income from services
we've got to remember
by and large for a balanced budget
expenditure and the money we get in are
pretty much the same apart from uh
various recharges and um Reserve
transfers so that chart with the staff
showed there again as a percentage of
expenditure is a realistic view of
our total uh commitment in terms of our
staff costs
what would be clearer I think for that
chart is if all of those segments in
that pie chart were to have percentages
as well as they're all numbers and
indeed I look back on last year's budget
and that chart did have percentages
there as well so
sorry
um but um that would probably help you
in in future if we could do that so um
but it is just just under the 51
councilor let me see sorry I've just
thank you chair I just wanted to do an
opportunity to come back on this
breakout of the climate change business
because I
you've got 337
for economic growth and climate change
plus 119 for climate change and
sustainability bringing a total of four
five six so one isn't broken out from
the other they're two separate items
so I'm just within the economic growth
and climate change how much of that is
climate change and how much of that is
economic growth that's that's what I'm
asking I don't think I
okay not it's one isn't a break out the
other two
um I'll try and explain so the first
chunk is um economic growth and climate
change the 337 and then listed below
that is all of those elements that make
up that chunk of it and then if you move
down the page you've got climate change
and biodiversity which is 119 000 so
that's the separate amount and it is
only one lot of 119 000 and as you can
see most of that expenditure is in
employees so a lot of those the staff
costs relating to those areas does that
make sense
yes thank you
thank you
are there any other questions
so if there are no further questions
um we can now move to debate
councils will be allowed to speak for
three minutes once for three minutes and
that will be timed
would anyone like to open the debate
councilor Barrett are you looking uh I
suppose
thank you
um yes it's it's
um I always find it very interesting
this time of year and the budget comes
out because everything calms down from
The Hectic period of November when we're
always at two and a half million in
deficit which seems to be the standard
position that the council finds itself
every October and November and we always
managed to balance the budget one way or
the other the rabbits come out the hat
and we end up
with a balanced budget
it happens every year the budget is only
a position that we have to go forward
it's never accurate it's our best guess
at going forward and that's not
necessarily our fault I have to say
having done it last year I think it's
extremely difficult for a council the
size of this to work on a one-year
settlement which comes in December the
14th or something like that really we
should be having a three-year budget
settlement we can plan better it's
better for our residents it's better for
everyone and I I think the sooner the
government gets his act together and
does that we will all have a far easier
time because it does cause stress to the
hard-working finance
department who having worked with them I
know they spend a lot of time going over
figures and a lot of these figures are
because they have to grasp that from the
air and luckily they do come down as
Council award indicated the
um
business rate support came in a million
pounds it wasn't anticipated that we
were going to get that so it is it is a
very difficult thing
um again we as the collector of the tax
I think are unfairly uh duped with the
um extra cost the 57 pounds from the
County Council and the 15 pounds from
the police and crime commissioner at our
five pounds and seven Pence a poultry
amount and look at what we provide so I
think
as much as uh it it's always annoying to
have to put the price at the
sounds like he's a customer doesn't it
or are we just talking about clients or
are we talking about
anyway but the fact we have to put that
up I think it does keep us in line with
where we need to be if we're going to
provide the services that we need and
one of the things I'm very pleased that
we haven't introduced is car parking
charges in Sudbury and Hadley that would
be disastrous for our high streets so
well done for not introducing it and
let's not have it come back please
thanks
[Music]
Council of beer
I wasn't quite expecting to follow my
colleague who I write but it'll come as
no surprise to any of you that are uh I
cannot agree with what has just been
said and I will not be supporting this
because
um we have to remember that the public
out there are paying more
uh they're struggling now to make ends
meet
um we only we all know somebody who's on
that breadline whether you go to a food
bank wherever you look at your council
tax bill whether you look at the energy
bills they are all going up
um you quoted the County Council the
police their amount you've got favor you
add on the town Parish councils it all
adds up it becomes considerably more the
County Council took a small amount one
point not 199 percent
uh Baba is being greedy they are taken
the full amount
and I don't think you should be I think
it should be a lot less
um the police precept
was over the top
and I told them at the time and I voted
against that
um
I do not trust you not to bring in car
parking charges I know you're going to
say it's the new Council they'll make
that decision but unfortunately a lot of
you will be returned in May you will
have the majority
and I'm sure I'm right that the cabinet
member already has permission to
implement them
charges whenever they want
so we're not likely to get any
discussion on it members bear that in
mind and Sudbury and Hadley members you
need to think very strongly about this
because they're the people that will
suffer
and the Terrence and what if you so no
you're not going to get my support I I
can't agree with my colleagues uh he
already knows that and um
I really appeal to people not to impose
this charge you are not getting value
for money we will end up getting cut uh
car parking charges brought into our
towns with this new Council if you lost
or in charge thank you
thank you councilor beer councilor James
oh councilor Busby first sorry
2.9 9
inflation's around 10 at the moment and
all our costs are going up by that and
you're quite right it would be nice to
be able to present a zero percent budget
and you could have done that we could
have done that had you in agreed to
having car parking charges but you can't
have it both ways there's only certain
amount of money going around and we have
to make decisions on how it's spent and
where the income comes from and I think
we've created a balanced budget which is
fair to all as I explained in my note
the difference between us and mid
Suffolk is they got in early on building
houses had we done that then we might
have had a few million pounds extra to
do a lot of things things like climate
change things like biodiversity
we'd like to spend more on that we would
like to do a lot more but we haven't got
the money
we just can't magic the funds up from
any from you know out of the wind it's
got to be
coming from the sources that we're aware
of
and yeah
2.9 is not a
figure that I would like to have had
zero would have been better especially
since mid-suffolk I think are going for
zero but
you know needs must I'm afraid people
sorry
thank you chair
um first I'd like to commend Melissa and
her team who've managed to Paul
together a balance budget despite the
challenges and um as Council must be
said the challenge is going forward
I've a couple of comments
looking at the budget summary it shows
that we have a net expenditure of 477
000 on economy regeneration and climate
change produced 95
000 on climate change sustainability
despite climate change showing is one of
the main concerns of our residents in
the survey completed last year
even taking into account the capital
program we're not going very far we have
only allocated an addition to 180 000
some EV charging points
at the same time that we're allocating
95 000 pounds of climate change with a
budgeted 270 235 000 for our commitments
for our Communications
two and a half times more to tell people
what we do and we actually budget in for
tackling what this Council has agreed is
an emergency
we also budgeted 685 000 Fresh Senior
leadership team
when agreeing their pay rise last year
we were told they would need to raise
their wage that we would lose them
including the director of housing
since then three directors have left
and since then the councilor says to
launch an in-depth review at the health
department
I'm not saying senior leaders should not
get a fair wage and I do agree it is
important
that we um keep our residents informed
of things that affect them however it
does not feel right that we're happy to
spend substantial sums on comms as well
as substantial trumps on a few people
talk about the job well only budget in
relatively small amounts on our key
priorities for tackling non-degreed
emergency
in terms of the recommendation before I
decision I am still undecided we do need
an agreed budget and I'm sure the
cabinet member will say that five pound
30 is only a small amount
and it may seem small fry in comparison
to the uterizing energy and the food
that we are experiencing
I have a small small increases here and
there all add up with increase from
County the PCC and possibly parish
councils as well
it won't just be an additional five
pounds 30 a year it will end up being a
substantial hit to people's budgets
at the same time I know that we have no
increase we may not be able to provide
services
perhaps the answer is getting a capable
government that actually cares what the
problems about the problems of local
government and residents are dealing
with thank you
Council Jameson
did you wish to respond to councilor
Busby
well I kind of agree with him really um
on the last Point anyway
but I as I said to councilor beer the
issue is we don't have the funds to
spend more if we did have we would do
um and I think the issue in terms of
payment to the staff
we have to be competitive
we lose very good people we've lost a
lot of good people over the last two or
three years and we found it
significantly harder to recruit people
of equal quality
and whilst there's a shortage in the
labor market you've got to offer a
competitive salary in a competitive
package and that's why we had to
increase the salaries the way we did so
I'm glad the people are earning a fair
wage which we had more money to to
Spirit around but maybe sometime in the
future
thank you Council Busby councilor Hinton
chairman I'd like to endorse what
councilor Jameson said about the finance
team the chair of overview and scrutiny
we've looked at this budget
what four times now five times counting
tonight it's five times because it keeps
on changing as government keeps on
coming up with different pots of money
that they're dishing out to different
people at different times so they've had
to modify the budget four times so far
before he even gets to us here so I
commend them and their team for all
their hard work and they've been doing
as far as the environment is concerned
Council Jameson probably Keen to know
that
the officers also worked on an
application to central government for
funding
for some electric car charging points
for res in our car parks for residents
who do not have access to off-road
parking because the County Council will
not let them have charging points to
charge their cars at the side of the
road
after 14 different modifications to the
application we were successful in
achieving it and it gained us some 330
odd thousand pounds to spend on these
electric car charging points we have to
supply 25 of it
there's about 80 000 we
had it does go to show that we are
thinking about the environment we are
taking opportunities
at every every time we can to secure
funding as it comes available from
central government but sometimes it
requires an awful lot of effort from our
officers and I think they do a sterling
job in trying to keep us ahead of the
game in terms of ground approval
thank you councilor Hinton any more
people who wish to
have you already spoken councilman okay
thank you councilor Barrett
thank you
um I think the Stark issue really with
the budget is the the increase in staff
costs that we've all picked up on the
1.66 million
um not to not to grow the workforce but
just to stay where we are
um I I'm really concerned that in the
future years what
what looks like a very motivational and
and to creating good packages for people
to come and work here actually gets
turned on its head because you can't
afford it and you have to make people
redundant and that would be a tragedy um
to have that that situation affecting uh
these these staff
um I'm I don't think it's not something
I'm going to
mean that I won't vote for the the
budget because
um I I know it's beyond our control the
increasing costs some of those are
externally imposed on this but I
as a council we it's something we need
to be very conscious of to to avoid this
slipping uh into into unsustainable
Realms and that's why I really wanted to
see staff course presented to you in the
budget as a percentage of
um uh expenditure or income either way
doesn't really matter but so that you
can identify as a future Council if
those staff costs are rising
um into a unsustainable level so that
you can make sure that it's it's steady
each year but um I understand that that
has not meant approval
so I will be supporting it
thank you councilor Barrett
councilor McCraw
thank you chair
um
I think it's important to remember I
think at some point either the leader or
the cabinet member referred to the
amount raised
through council tax and this 5.3
um
if I have 30 a week increase it's a year
a year increases Tempe a week and the
amount being raised by this 2.99 percent
is something like two hundred thousand
pounds
the increase in our budgetary pressures
is far in excess of that and sometimes I
think it's easily overlooked that
council tax does not provide
there are a variety of sources for our
income and they come from a variety of
our own Investments for example which
have been much criticized in the past
but actually it turned out to be pretty
crucial things considered sifco has been
success a lot of things have been a
success yes we've had government grants
and we've continued to get those our
treasury management works we look for
every opportunity every penny we can get
but it does not all fall on the council
taxpayer a lot of it in fact the vast
majority of it comes from elsewhere so
let's not say that this is an increase
that entirely falls on the council
taxpayer I think it's an important point
and I
thank you councilman craw
if anyone else who hasn't spoken would
like to speak
thank you councilor Ward
thank you chairman yeah it has been a
difficult budget setting period this
year
um much more difficult than in past
years Council of Bearer but we have got
there
um and yeah all councils are unhappy
with the government's uh settlement it
comes in late it is only one year but
they keep postponing a three-year
settlement we have to live with that
but you will see
despite having a set about a balanced
budget we have still had to rely on
about 2 million pounds worth of
recharges and a million pounds worth of
movement from Reserves
so setting that context the five pound
Thirty increase the 2.99 is modest
and I would probably point out councilor
beer the County Council was not 1.99 it
was 3.99 you've forgotten the two
percent adult social care precept
um so it's included within the 57 pound
51.
now you're not going to vote for this
you've said so
but you did vote for that 57 pound 51
when you're a county councilor the week
before last at County Council
this time this time last year you
silent please councilor beer
no
not you you had your opportunity
if you're not silent I'll have to have
you removed from the room
this time last year the same we had a
five pound increase you wouldn't vote
for that you voted for nearly 48 pounds
increase in the county council's budget
uh council tax that's nearly a hundred
pounds in two years that you have voted
for so the residents of corner I need to
know this there's an election coming you
don't like voting for small council tax
Rises but you will vote for big ones
Madam chairman I really should be
allowed to reply when I'm being accused
for things like that I made it quite
clear at the beginning of the position
into order
it's by the monetary monetary sir that
you can make a point of clarification is
that correct thank you madam chairman
well I'm going to say could you sit down
well I'm going to say is I pointed today
quite clearly at the beginning how I
voted and the reasons for it you are
being greed you've gone for the full
amount thank you
thank you councilor bear Council Ward
would you like to continue please yeah
so as I was saying it's a modest
increase but it is a necessary one it's
raising 188 000 pounds the council tax
base increase another 99 000 pounds but
it's necessary for us to set a balanced
budget and we've got a balanced budget
it's a good one and it will allow us to
continue and to deliver the services
that our residents uh have come to
expect and and need because they are all
suffering from uh cost of living crisis
on top of covid but we are being able to
help them and help them a lot so I think
we we need to congratulate our team our
section 151 officer and her team for
producing what is an excellent budget
for this Council so I think we should
all support it because it is something
that will set us up well for the next
financial year thank you chairman
thank you Council Ward
so councilor Busby did you have anything
you'd like to add
thank you Jeff
thank you councilor Busby in that case
in accordance with Council procedure
rule 19.3
immediately after any voters taken at a
budget decision meeting of the council
the names of councilors who cast a vote
for the decision or against the decision
or who abstained from voting shall be
recorded in the minutes of the meeting
I will now ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair and I just wanted to
clarify the difference the subtle
differences that normally we do
electronic voting and it's recorded um
the next day um on the minutes and
published on a website
this is an addition so it will be
recorded on the website and in the
minutes so that's where we hit the the
actual statutory requirement to record
our our budget voting so councilors that
is now showing in blue for you to cast
your vote
Council McCall I apologize for this as a
point of order but will the names of the
members voting for against are
abstaining be revealed teams
within this meeting or uh we'd have to
wait till the minutes are published or
tomorrow it will be revealed tomorrow
morning on the website thank you
councilor beer can I take your photo
please with pleasure against
cancer Dawson can I take your vote as
well please
um chair that is 1942 against and one
abstention
thank you so that is carried
so we'll move on with the agenda now
item nine BC 22 42 housing revenue
account
2023 24 budget
I would like to invite councilor Busby
to introduce this item and move the
recommendations in the report councilor
Busby
I must becoming Busby District councilor
isn't it um
anyway the HRA the latest forecast for
this year predicts an adverse variance
of 825 000 against a budgeted surface of
511. the key factors in this position
are the additional costs being incurred
to address the covid recreated backlog
in void and responsive repairs as well
as increasing staff and material costs
due to inflation
as a consequence of this significant
period of increasing costs and reducing
customer satisfaction with our aging
stock we took the decision to carry out
an urgent Diagnostic and transformation
program within Building Services
this program which aims to provide and
Implement Excellence is well underway
there are three separate work streams
compliance assets and direct labor
organization
the Journey to Excellence will take
several years to complete however
members can expect to see steady
progress over the next 18 months
however this will not come cheaply
we had five years of one percent annual
rent reductions which creates a serious
dent in our income over 30 years
the current arrangement of five years of
CPI plus one percent had begun to
mitigate the impact of the rent
reductions but the cost of living crisis
has resulted in the government ditching
this rent settlement
there is now a significant risk to the
HRA as the recent rent reductions and
now cap leaves the council at risk of
not being able to meet its legal
obligations
the council's total cost of services is
budgeted to increase by just over 4
million or 56 percent whilst income will
only go up by one and a half million
August 8 percent
reserves only provide one-off funding
and the council must have regard to
financing its future expenditure
know that any increase in rent will be
burdensome
titling now
but unfortunately we're left with no
choice
over 30 years the cumulative effect of
going for a five percent increase
instead of a seven percent increase
would be a 10 million pound shortfall
what I can offer is a small crumb of
comfort the average social rent will be
less than 50 percent of that being asked
in the private sector
so it's against this backdrop that I
move the recommendations I ask for a
seconder and I'd also like to thank the
housing team and the finance team
in a very difficult period to provide
this budget thank you
thank you councilor Busby could I have a
second here please
that's the general Osborne thank you
we'll now move to questions
cancers may ask as many questions as
they wish however they must be relevant
to the subject under discussion and must
be a question
would anyone like to open the questions
councilor Jameson thank you
thank you chair
um do we know
how much of the increases rent increases
uh poorest residence on housing benefit
in Universal Credit will actually feel
so can you help please
oh Deborah thank you
sorry I couldn't hear the question
could you repeat
yeah sure
um do we know how much of the rent
increase is our poorest residence on
housing benefit and Universal Credit
will actually feel
how much that that actually feel on a
so I think I think it would be it would
be better for me to provide you an
emailed response with some detail on
that
Osborne did you want to add to this yeah
thank you madam chairman thank you I
think
um as our director of housing said
she'll provide a more detailed one but I
think we've got 68 of our residents are
on housing benefit so that's quite a
high proportion and what they get in
housing benefit will be dependent on
what their income is so if that rent
Falls within
um
the calculation that's done for their
housing benefit
then they will get continue to get for
example maximum benefit but then it
decreases as their income is is
increased as well if that if that makes
sense so it's not one we can answer
tonight because it purely depends on the
calculation of what their benefit is and
at this point of time we don't know how
many people there are we can get that
from the share Revenue partnership
um
in a few weeks time if that's okay we
can provide that and we can provide that
response to all members and it won't be
in time to go on the minutes but perhaps
we can do some sort of addendum to it so
members of the public listening in will
also get to know that information as
well when we provide it
thank you councilor Osborne
cancer beer
thank you madam chairman could I ask do
we know what the current
um Market rent of a council a
three-bedroom Council houses say today
and what will it be uh um on the 7th of
April uh it with the increase it's just
that quite often you hear weird and
wonderful figures about Council rents
and I do accept that they are much
cheaper than in the private sector but
they are now considerable with all the
other costs that people are having to
have so even tell me what the market
rate of an average three bedroom houses
with your permission
thank you for the question um yeah the
average monthly rent for a private
landlord is 875 pounds per month
the average
875 pounds the social rent after the
increase will average
452. obviously it varies between one two
three and four or five bedroom but the
average is 452 and for affordable rent
after the increase it will be 596. so
it's still a lot lot cheaper than the
private sector
okay any further questions
if there are no further questions or now
move to debate
councils will only be allowed to speak
once for three minutes and this will be
timed
who would like to start the debate
would anyone like to open the debate
councilor Osborne thank you thank
when we approve an increase in anything
it's always really difficult not an easy
choice to make and to prove to approve
an increase in the rates to the seven
percent that we're proposing tonight is
even challenging and especially at this
particular time when we've got a cost of
living crisis and people are struggling
to pay their rent they're struggling to
pay their heating bills
but as has already been alluded to for
five years the government implemented a
CPI at one reduction in the rent and you
never ever catch up on that we have lost
that income over a five-year period
in addition we have an aging housing
stock which adds significant strain to
the repairs and maintenance bill
retrofitting our homes to help the
environment and reduce our tenants
utility bills is vital without it we
increase this will be at risk there's no
doubt about it with the increase in
materials which in some cases is 35
percent we have a challenge in meeting
the most basic repairs and maintenance
this is even before considering the
green agenda and bringing our homes up
to EPC grade C and above and I think at
the moment we're only about 50 there 52
members will also be hearing in the
coming months about our proposal to
develop a creating great places scheme
this will be a significant investment
each year in our communities and will be
led by the tenants
again without the rent increase this
will be at risk through our
transformation program our Capital
program which plans to replace kitchens
bathrooms heating systems windows and
doors is on course to start in April in
fact we've already started it on some
developments without the rent to
increase this program will also be at
risk
so members you can see as a difficult
choice that it is if we don't make this
choice to increase this rent
then our tenants will suffer extensively
and if I can say I know councilor Busby
has quoted some figures
um if no if we don't do an increase at
all up to year 30 we will lose 58 and a
half million pounds in our HRA budget
three percent
33.335 million and as councilor Busby is
has alluded to five percent will be in
excess he quoted 10 million it will
actually be in excess of 10 million
so as difficult as this choice is
tonight I do hope members appreciate and
understand the need to make this
increase together with our tenants and
people that are listening to this
meeting
thank you very much councilor Osborne
would anyone else like to join the
debate or have any comments
councilman crawl
it's a point that needs to be made
it's already been given in figures but
I'd just like to put it in a stalker way
every time we have a report we have a
risk management assessment and our
strategic risk register shows that at
any given moment in this instance we the
risk is that we may be unable to react
in a timely and effective manner or
effective way to financial demands
the likelihood of that on a scale of one
to four is described as three
the impact if that happens is described
as four multiply the two figures
together we get a figure of twelves
three times four
of a maximum possible risk that we
assess at 16.
it's a significant risk and that's why
we should be voting for this thank you
for councilor Lindsay
thanks chair I I think I just I think
it's worth saying it my questions to
councilor Osborne earlier about the
housing
the mess that is in Building Services
I
of course it needs to be addressed and
we need to probably you know two million
more in Building Services
for the next financial year fine but we
really need I I feel
we've suddenly got an announcement in
November that there was this emergency
investigation into the housing
department
I really feel we need to be kept
abreast of this and a bit more openness
in future about what's going on and when
we start to tackle this the this backlog
I've had enough of the excuse of covid
that finished two years ago against
um
that it's not just kovid there are
problems in the housing in the building
services department and I know it
because I hear it from my tenants in my
ward all the time
um and and constantly having to
to to get housing officers to deal with
things
things that shouldn't have just happened
and they're not
so
I I'm going to vote in favor of this
because of course we need to
we need to put more money into into this
and the only way to do that really is to
to increase rents
um I appreciate that but but um I I just
want to lay down a marker that
um
this we can't let this go we can't we
can't continually hear that things that
this the housing repair backlog is being
tackled and then not have any evidence
for the fact
thank you Council John Osborne wishes to
respond to your comments
I completely disagree that we we did it
behind closed doors so remember brief is
we contacted our tenants who uh where
there was a compliant issue on that
particular property
um and
we self-referred ourselves we weren't
investigated we self-referred ourselves
because we had identified there was a
problem and in actual fact I have to say
there are 98 of other councils that are
in a much worse position with compliance
and we are
and of the
um homes that have been identified with
a compliance issue not being
non-compliant
um
I know the figures are wrong I know the
figures shouldn't be five
five two men it should be zero but it is
only five percent realistically to put
it in proportion and of that
five percent 99 of those are
non-compliant is due to
we are in the process we do we send out
um we do two site visits with the
agreement of the tenant and then when
the tenant doesn't allow us access we
then have to take an injunction and
that's where we are with 99 of those
cases so you can see that it's not all
our fault there you go you know going
back on to the Building Services I agree
with you it is we are in a position
where it does need to improve and that's
why we're putting in money into the
diagnostic review that we're doing and
the transformation plan to make sure
that in a few months time we don't
whoever's in my shoes then doesn't have
to stand up and say we are improving
they can actually stand here and say
there is Improvement a little
Improvement Big Little Steps big times
thank you
thank you councilor Osborne Council
award
um
I don't have anything else councilor
Osborne said everything I was going to
say actually about um the referral to
the regulator and the compliance issues
um we're on top of it and that
it was all explained to members we had a
full briefing and um there's there's
nothing that that's been withheld and um
we're progressing the numbers as Council
Osborne has said we're low anyway but we
are getting through them and uh the
access issues are proven problematic but
we'll get there
and most other councils are in the same
position
thank you councilor Ward councilor
Dawson
um yes I wonder if I could just asked
councilor Osborne um my figures might
not be up to date but I believe there
are 116 that haven't got up to date
electrical safety certificates
70 are overdue a gas safety inspection
and whilst in the private sector
um most people wouldn't be able to rent
these properties out
so I'm actually left wondering
is our global insurance policy covering
these 200 houses or is it null and void
at this point in time because this
compliance has obviously not been done
to answer that all
you answer questions on insurance and
liability thank you okay uh would would
you like to answer that thank you
thank you so so the situation we're in
at the moment is we are taking action
um against
um those tenants which unfortunately
won't give us access and those are the
cases
uh being referred to so in that case
um we are covered by the insurance
because we're proactively working with
the tenants and seeking
um to get an injunction to get into
those properties
thank you councilor beer
thank you madam chairman
um well I I wanted to support councilor
Robert Lindsay uh in his comments
because
um there is problems as you know you're
well aware of them uh in the Council of
houses uh with repairs there are people
that are having jobs done they've had
contractors come in they say they'll be
back next week two months three months
six months later we've had to chase them
up and we get them back in now I know
that's not your fault but what you are
responsible for is making sure that the
people who are implying them
get get on to these people because we're
being let down by these contractors we
had another situation uh a leak and roof
they came along and they'd done it and
actually they made matters worse and the
roof leaked even more so we have uh
cases of dampness in houses and they
come along say well you mustn't have
your windows closed you need more air
through the place and what have you
they've got the heating on so there's
all these problems there which are not
helping and also
there's the situation that we need to
make sure that when uh we send
contractors in that there is an action
plan that can be followed because I'll
give you a very quick example a lady in
her 80 late 80s in a wheelchair was
having a new window put in and they put
uh windows in which we had to open like
that but she couldn't even lean over the
sink she couldn't get there I mean how
stupid is that sort of in
um now all right she may not have said
that to them I can't be sure about that
but the point is that somebody should
have seen that situation when they went
into that house to to measure up the
window and what have you and think right
with this ladies in a wheelchair she's
never made a lean over to open the
window with the handles top and bottom
they need to be at the bottom so that's
simple little things like that but we we
are falling down on it I'm afraid
um we we tried to catch up to date for
years ago but I think it's got worse I
honestly think it's got worse and I
think you need to be jumping on those
people that are responsible for carrying
out what it is we're asking for and
these repairs to be done thank you madam
chairman
would anyone else like to um add to the
debate
thank you so if there's no one else
counselor Busby is there anything else
you would like to add
no I need just to say really that yeah
we're aware of the situation and we
totally agree it's got to get better and
it needs to get better quickly
we'll take a little bit of time it will
take a certain amount of money I
certainly have every confidence in the
team that we now have that will deliver
what we all want to see it's an issue I
know councilor Lindsay said kovid a long
time ago well it
is still affecting people but it it did
have a significant impact on our ability
to catch up with the backlog and our
housing stock is old it does require a
lot of work doing to it and of course
the regulations change rate on a fairly
regular basis which means we're always
chasing our tail
certainly I have confidence that we will
be able to deliver what you would like
to see in the housing in the future
thank you for that kind answer thank you
thank you councilor Busby
so now in accordance with Council
procedure rule
19.3 immediately after any vote is taken
at a budget decision meeting of the
council the names of councils who cost a
vote for decision or against the
decision or who abstained from voting
shall be recorded in the minutes of the
meeting
I will now ask the corporate manager
governor and Civic office to conduct the
electronic vote thank you chair that is
now showing in blue for councilors to
cast their vote
can I take your boat against
thank you chair that is 19 votes for one
against and two abstentions
thank you so that is carried we'll now
take a five minute break
and we'll be back at five past seven
we'll resume the meeting at five past
seven thank you
okay everybody we're going to reopen the
meeting now
thank you
thank you members welcome back to the
meeting
we'll now get straight on to the next
item on our agenda which is item number
paper BC
2243 case for a new joints Depot
I'd like to keep as much of the debate
as possible in the open session
so counselors who wish to discuss the
budget costings such as the breakdown of
the 12 million pound 12 million pound
should indicate so it can then move to
closed session but I would prefer if we
can to do as much of this as we can in
the open session
and as this is the councilor Busby show
today I would like to invite councilor
Busby again to introduce this item and
to move the recommendations in the
report councilor Bosley our prime
minister's question time isn't it I'll
tell you what I wish I didn't have the
key issue issuing reports that are based
on Aging stock
I'm taking personal affront on it anyway
we have two waste public realm Depots in
stowmark in Sudbury with Building
Services mainly operating out of a
smaller Depot at Great Wenham however
both Depots are over 50 years old
feel and no longer fit for purpose
maintaining the properties is becoming
increasingly more expensive
the sites are becoming obsolete due to
their layout and the number of
operations being conducted from them
expanding population within the district
has seen 6 000 new properties over the
last eight years with a further five
thousand predicted for the next five
years
the resource and waste strategy
represents a particular challenge they
include the introduction of separate
household food waste collections the
collection of glass from the curbside
segregated fibers and containers and
there could be a need for similar
changes to our business waste
collections
these changes will put further pressure
on the existing Depot estate and will
constrain the services that can be
delivered
operational service savings and income
generation could be delivered in the
order of 75 to 150 000 per annum from a
single shared Depot
a new Depot would improve staff
well-being providing a modern fit for
purpose accommodation that meets
operational needs and AIDS working
effectively and efficiently
however significant capital investment
is needed to secure a new Depot it's in
the order of 12 million pounds across
both districts so 6 million from baber
this would provide a site of
approximately 3.25 hectares eight Acres
an accommodation for 200 operational
staff
this would be more than double the
current operational capacity
we have considered the options and
filled a single shared Depot serving
both districts is the Right Way Forward
this day all I'm asking you to do is to
include the lighter costs in the budget
this does not mean that we are committed
to spend it further discussions
decisions and a full business case
will be agreed later this year
so at this stage all we're looking for
is permission to put the money into the
budget so we can carry on
I propose the recommendations and asked
for a second thank you thank you
councilor Busby could I have a second to
please Council award thank you
so now move to questions counselors may
ask as many questions as they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion and must be a
question
who would like to open the questions
counselor Lindsay
um
why genuine why um
can't we just demolish these aging
Depots and rebuild them where they are
um so we still have three Depots they're
just more
modern facilities more fit for purpose
the reason I ask is just
with electrification hopefully coming at
some stage we may need more demos
because it with with charging with
places for
uh vehicles to charge
um so they've got a shorter to travel
before they reach a charging Point
that's that's the reason I asked that
but also
um It just strikes me it's simpler
build where what we've already on what
we've already got rather than sell
something and with all the risk that
that entails and buy something with all
the rest of that entails thank you
uh well a couple of reasons one is uh
there won't be big enough the sites the
current sites that we've got wouldn't be
big enough even if we managed to make it
a much more streamlined operation on
each site it still wouldn't
cope with the extra five thousand houses
and the 8 000 that we've already had
that's I mean that's a lot of extra
houses that's you know it's almost like
a new town they'll be having to deal
with
they wouldn't be as efficient
um would have staff spread around what
we have currently
it doesn't work as well as it ought to
and
most of the waste still has to come back
towards the great break in an area
anyway so
the round trip would be the same
wherever you started the round trip from
thank you Council of us be councilor
beer
thank you madam chairman
um
somewhere and I won't quote it
um the figures show that it's costing us
more to run these places and and the
expenditure is going up all the time but
can you just tell me why
uh we decided in our wisdom a few years
back that we would no longer buy petrol
or diesel whatever it was to serve as
the fleet that we've got at the
Alexander Road Depot in Sudbury I'm told
that they have to go back to stay Market
or even great bacon to fill up I mean
now if that's the case
we've caused them to endure extra
expenditure I mean that's not um
sensible at all
thank you have our officer answered that
thank you
don't don't think my seat's planned in
um we're not we're not going back to um
from Sudbury to stowmarket to fuel up
this refilling facilities of both Depots
with the hvo feel in bunded tanks at
both the depot so that's not the case
I'm not sure we've found that out
thank you councilor Jameson
thank you
um maybe too early to answer this but if
we're combining three sites to one will
this result in job Cuts particularly
within the office staff so
if I speak very good
at a very early stage yet I mean I don't
know one would hope that the
staff will be more efficient being in
one location and we hope that the same
number of Staff would be able to deal
with more demand so maybe not maybe we
have to increase the staff numbers
demand is going up and waste collection
is getting more complex in the future
it's not getting simpler
and the Building Services what we've
just heard the kind of work that they're
going to be under so
respect probably
councilor Simon Barrett
um is this another
um I'm just trying to find out where
this actually uh instigate from because
clearly the cabinet never instigates
anything uh it's never already parties
Manifesto
so presumably uh this is an officer
driven initiative
um
answer
Buzz beef what do you have to know
I guess yes it is an officer driven
initiative
they've presented us with the problems
the that we're facing now in terms of
and the extra cost that we're incurring
in operating these three aging depots
and uh yeah it's down to us to cut they
come up with some solutions some options
and we've decided that the the best
option is to have a single site yeah
Council award
yes you can what why is we also um are
any sites being looked at in baber
District or are they just being looked
at in mid-suffolk
yes
no we haven't
so I can't tell you where they're going
to be how big they're going to be
I've got an idea of the size that we
need but until we've got this money put
into the budget we're not proceeding any
further with this project
it would be foolish to go off
and start looking at sites and trying to
get quotes and things like that without
having the funds available to do it
so is this money going to be uh taken
out of capital programs that are
currently in the budget for things like
born gate Precinct Hamilton Road
is there a dimension of that Capital
which doesn't get spent by the way so I
mean on our current uh our current form
I mean we put these in the capital
program we'll still be talking about
this in 15 years time
but of course that isn't a project that
benefits our residents this is a project
that benefits our Naval gazing internal
systems so normally that gets done
fairly quickly like shall I say senior
leadership team pay Rises
I think senior leadership pay Rises have
got anything to do with capital
every Capital project will have to stand
and fall on its own on its own two feet
it will have to determine before we go
ahead with any project whether it's
financially viable to do it
uh this doesn't take money from any
other project we will have to look at
how to finance it
the same as we will any other project we
just because it's in a capital budget
does not mean we have the funds readily
available
to spend we will have to borrow to
deliver it councilor Ward
yeah
Council Barrett of course is not in
anyone's Manifesto the this sort of
thing is a change in operational
requirements and these things happen
during the course of any any council's
lifetime the fact no matter is the
Depots are no longer fit for purpose
they're not big enough to hold the
vehicles that we've got now they're
certainly not big enough to hold the
vehicles we're going to need to meet
things like rules which has been
explained earlier which is coming down
from central government so we have to
respond to changes like this and and
this is what this is It's a response to
changes just as the change in our floor
plate usage in this building is was not
in anyone's Manifesto but it's a change
to how we want to operate so these
things happen and we have to adapt and
respond and and make the provisions as
and when we need to and his Council of
Busby has said it's just a capital
provision at the moment that will be
added to the budget
helpless
thank you chair
um I'm looking at it from the
um budgeting and get the money now I am
worried that we're losing yet another
thing out of Sudbury area so we will
have nothing
from baber everything seems to be
outside of our perimeter so surely if
you're looking at this would it not you
have the epicenter of a hurricane or
whatever that it would be in the middle
between sort of Suffolk and favor not
right at the end on the borders of it
which is how it looked to me it was
going to be so surely and if you're
thinking about the cost of the fuel and
things like that you know could that not
be considered thank you
yes it will be considered
um I don't think that somebody's losing
anything I mean we certainly would
want to make really good use of the the
depot space that was vacated
um
again no had plans of that yet but it
may bring more jobs than currently
done at the the depot side so it could
be good news for Sudbury
and yes we'll take into account
where it's places
I in theory yes ideally somewhere
between Sudbury and Stone Market sounds
logical
but it isn't because the roads are awful
to get everywhere else in the district
and if they all have to end up going
back to Great blakenham to get rid of
the load then
it doesn't matter where they start
they've still got a round trip
the same haven't they
yeah all of these things are to be
investigated before we come up with any
proposals that will be made
councilor beer
thank you madam chairman
um well I'm not sure I can agree that it
won't be a loss to Sudbury an area I'm
sure it will be a great loss to
suffering there along with all the other
things we're losing but that's a soyed
um yes you may smile about it but that's
uh how I feel and I think it's how a lot
of the public out there will think that
another thing being taken away from
Sudbury but will you be consultant
very closely with the workforce because
they're the people on the ground who
know the answers to a lot of the
problems that you encounter
and if you ended up going nearer to
great blaken I mean a lot of the
workforce I do know live quite locally
in Sudbury cornard and waldenfield and
if they've got to travel you know a
further distance it could be detrimental
to them and their jobs so I think you
know there's a bit more to this than
just saying that um we should move all
right you're saying you're going to
investigate it
um I don't quite know how you're going
to do this until you find the money I
mean borrowing money isn't such a good
idea but um I still think at the end of
the day it will be a loss to the Sudbury
area thank you that's supposed to be
um
well I think
the thought that we don't provide
Sudbury with anything is
ridiculous
we've spent
well we've hopefully we're going to
provide them with a world-class Health
Center
we've helped spend a fortune on
well I'm sure the great cornard
residents will benefit from it being
being a better center with better
equipment and
Etc
we're doing our best for Sudbury we're
trying to make the park an improved area
I know it's taken time but we're still
trying to do that
we have plans for Hamilton Road but
again the finances for that are a thing
that's probably slowing us down on that
one
but we do have a lot of plans for
suffering
and I'd like to think that said we Town
Council have got plans for themselves
and they're talking with us about them
sorry um you are correct in that I would
hope that we would talk to the drivers
as well because as I say the people that
are doing the job usually know the
answers don't they
Council John Osborne
thank you madam chairman um yeah just on
on that point the investment in Sudbury
if I could also add to that that baby
District Council have invested oh they
do invest 34 000 a year in in brand new
CCTV
and Sudbury certainly get the benefit of
that although they invest 10 000 pounds
themselves each year they've put up the
34 000 each year and that's proven to be
really effective so
is there any work of the art CCTV so
that's an added investment to that in
regards to the um Wenham Depot about
knocking it down and starting again
the access is impossible absolutely
impossible I drove out there a few weeks
ago to have a look at it and I could
first of all I couldn't find it and then
it is well just as you get there as well
but you have to go down a little Country
Lane and then the access into the site
itself is very limited so it would be
impossible and I'm sure the residents in
great well and would not want us wine in
the road
on the day a brand new Depot so that's
on that one I also on the staff issue
that Peter beer has referred to I
actually took a trip out there to have a
look at the facility itself and to talk
to the staff and although they like
working there they understand that it is
no longer fit for purpose just doesn't
suit the needs that we need as a local
Authority moving forward and as for
benefiting our residents
our tenants will certainly benefit
because if we get bigger premises we can
hold bigger stock in that particular on
that particular site so instead of
having to go to
um suppliers and be told it's not there
you're going to wait a few weeks and you
don't want our residents having to
continue to wait weeks or months for a
repair to be done it will be there we'll
have access to it straight away so in
that respect our tenants will most
certainly benefit amongst other things
as
well
it's been pointed out to me I should
have I should have remembered that
actually Peter in in the report 5.7
a staff working group with
representatives from each of the
operational Services has been set up and
has supported
the preparation of this initial business
case staff will be fully consulted if
budget is secured to progress this
project and alternative options have
been identified so yes you're right
so are there any more questions because
otherwise oh sorry Council Jameson
so just to clarify for me the Six
Million Pound you mentioned
recommendation is that just for the land
purchase costs and there's going to be
more
afterwards
a very expensive no hopefully it's the
total cost so okay
thank you are there any more questions
otherwise we'll move into debate
okay so we'll now move into debate would
anyone like to open the debate although
we've almost been into debate with some
of the
uh questions
um any councilor Hinton
one I would just like to say I think
that this
proposal is sound
nickel
when you consider that all the waste has
to be taken to great break in them at
the moment have something close to there
is logical
when I look at the
Bandit countries we tend to call it
along the Suffolk Essex border
it's uh it's a little bit difficult to
see why Sudbury is complaining
um
especially when you consider that the
bring site that we all use in my ward
which is at Manning tree
have gone over to a booking system which
you cannot access because you have a CO
postcode and I know that brantham which
has an IP postcode can access it but
they still do not recognize co7 as a
postcode that they can book because I've
got several residents who've been trying
and trying and trying and still can't
get through to it because Essex have
blocked it out now they say that they
haven't and they're going to adjust
things and all the rest of it but in the
meantime they can't slot to take their
rubbish down there which means they then
have to take it to Hadley happy
environmentally friendly
so it's there's joined up thinking
needed on you know in all aspects and
perhaps
if I can just float this
there is facility great Wenham to have a
ring site in there
who knows who we'll see but I think that
this is a a good move by baber to give
it a combined Depot so that the men in
the in the trucks don't have to spend
all their time sitting in the truck
driving around the countryside which I'm
sure they like doing but I'm sure we
would rather they were picking up the
rubbish from the houses
okay
let's not have a debate about them
well I'm not really interested
um
say that
there has been no decision that we're
looking at great blakenham it will be
looked at the same as anywhere else but
it could be anywhere along perhaps along
the A14 or even along the a12 it it'll
be on a road that hopefully will provide
reasonable access but
please don't think it's been decided
that great bacon it hasn't
cut some Acro it's just a point of
information I think it might help clear
things up for counselor Hinton as my
neighboring
um Ward at Ransom Branson became aware
of this a couple of weeks ago raised it
with the shared waste partnership for
Suffolk through councilor arthi and the
officers concerned then they contacted
Suffolk County Council Suffolk County
this basically is not the IP postcodes
don't work either I believe and the
Branson post in post Casino 11. so they
don't work we did a test purchase on the
Friday of the week when we had it
reported it was agreed between Suffolk
County Council and Essex County Council
that there would be reciprocal
Arrangements at both these waste centers
obviously they may not yet have
reprogrammed their software to accept
Colchester 11 or cultures to seven
postcodes but the principle is
established that there is a reciprocal
Arrangement because people from Essex
use the Sudbury
waste recycling center and it would be
absurd to have anything else happen we
all want to have waste recycled so
blocking it blocking it would be stupid
so just wanted to make sure that that's
understood in case people got the wrong
impression we need to make sure that
both Essex and Suffolk cut that
reciprocal Arrangement into practice I I
think we're trying to talk about the
Depot at the moment so shall we um try
and keep to that subject now please
let's not uh
diversify too much away from the depot
any more questions on the new Depot idea
please councilor Lindsay
yeah I'm the the notes to this say that
no no direct environmental implications
but
my concern is
just trying to hint out at my earlier
question
you know the current we've got two waste
their pose one more or less serving
mid-suffer and one more or less serving
baber but there's always an instinct I
think with with local authorities
centralize everything and because
there's a tiny bit you could shave off
course I'm not not convinced it's always
the right answer
um because you you then get Laurie's
driving further by definition if you've
only got one Depot develop you'll have
lorries picking up waste all the way
from the peninsula shortly Peninsula are
up to where the north of mid Suffolk is
um the eye or somewhere so distances
Lori's travel is going to increase as a
result of this this proposal so um I
just wonder if there's any been any
assessment of
the likely impact of
um Lorry movements and Diesel emissions
um as a result of this thank you
thank you councilman the answer is yes
because it obviously affect the cost of
operation if if they're having to travel
more miles incur more fuel costs
um
and look to be honest there's no
guarantee that we will find an ideal
site and we may have to come back to you
and say
can't do it you need two sites but it
may not be that the two sites that we
then select are the two sites that we've
currently got they're not suitable
and they may be suitable for something
that's better and that will bring income
into us to enable us to pay for for this
project
are we just at this stage just looking
at very early days but we need to get on
with it because
the Depots don't last forever
does anyone else want to watch the
debate
cuts the water do you want to say
something
yeah just just a few words
obviously there are issues and people
have articulated the issues here but
it's not just a matter of needing to
replace the buildings on the site so
you've heard that the sites themselves
are no longer a purpose there's not
enough space we need more space because
we're going to have more receptacles but
the different uh waste streams that
we're going to have to collect we're
going to have to
many more Vehicles so we need more space
now we've got here
um proposals and and estimated costs of
a new site shared between the two
districts one single site
we'll get operational savings we'll get
some additional service income perhaps
and we'll also get and we haven't
mitigated the um the capital provision
and the likely cost of the site the new
site but um we could also get a quite
significant Capital receipts from
selling the current size so
um six million we're talking about here
per council is probably a worst case
scenario
but you've got to remember as has been
pointed out we may not find one side
clearly one site is going to give us
huge operational efficiencies
but if we have to have two sites well
clearly the current two sites are not
fit for purpose they're not big enough
so we need two new sites
and I can imagine that if sharing the
cost of one site is going to be six
million pound per Council buying two new
sites is going to be a lot more than
that per Council
so I think we need to work on the the
basis that trying to find one site is
the best thing to do
and as an initial start in terms of
making a capital provision
this paper makes a lot of sense and we
can take it forward and and investigate
more and come up with a proper business
case and also looking to see if we can
find a suitable site
just one last thing and we we've had a
couple of comments about taking things
away from Sudbury and Sudbury losing
this and suddenly losing that in the
past few years we have spent over five
million pounds investing in things in
Sudbury we spent a fortune on the town
um
so we do a lot for Sudbury we've got and
has already been articulated earlier a
few minutes ago there's a lot more
planned
Sudbury gets a huge amount probably more
than its fair share and when compared
with other parts of the district
particularly those further east which
don't really get much of a look in in
terms of investment so
yeah
so in conclusion this this makes a lot
of sense this paper and I'm happy to
Second it and vote in favor of it thank
you cuts for Busby is there anything
you'd like to add
no thanks
thank you so in that case we'll now move
to to the vote
um I'd like to ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote thank you
thank you chair that is now showing in
flu if the councilors to cast their vote
thank you
councilor beer can I take your vote I'm
now against
okay
chair that is sixteen four five against
and one abstention
thank you that is carried
we'll now move on to item 14 on the
agenda BC 2244
joint capital investment and treasury
management strategies
2022 324
and it's not you this time councilor
Busby you'll be pleased to know but
unfortunately councilor Horan who was
due to be taking this paper is unwell so
I'd like to invite Rebecca Hewitt to
introduce this item thank you Rebecca
thank you chair
um on behalf of cancer Herron I am
pleased to introduce this report which
was discussed at the Joint audit and
standards committee on 30th of January
under the sit for treasury management
code of practice and the Prudential code
both published in 2021 and the d-luck
investment guidance published in 2018 we
are determined we are required to
determine separate capital investment
and treasury management strategy
statements and Prudential indicators
annually before the start of each
Financial year
the strategies and indicators to be
approved are in the appendices to this
report
the capital strategy shows that capital
expenditure plan for 23.24 including
Curry Ford's is 23 million of which 14.3
million will be funded by borrowing
limits and boundaries for borrowing are
set as part of the Prudential indicators
the strategy shows that projected
borrowing will not exceed these limits
the ongoing impact on the UK from the
war in Ukraine together with higher
inflation uncertain government policy
and a deteriorating economic Outlook
will be major influences on the
council's treasury management for 23 24.
at the time of writing this report the
Authority's treasury management advisor
was forecasting that bank of England
bank rate will rise to four percent in
the first quarter and 4.25 in the second
quarter of 2023 and remain at this level
until the first quarter of 2024.
there has only been one significant
change to treasury limits since last
year the amount that baber can invest in
mid in mid-suffolk has been increased to
5 million from 2 million
thank you
thank thank you
I'm sure we all wish uh councilor Horan
well and we all miss his jokes
um can I now have a proposer for this
page please thank you councilor Ward and
now can I have a secondary as well
please
councilor Simon Barrett
thank you so
um now we'll move to questions
counselors may ask as many questions as
they wish but they must be relevant to
the subject under discussion and must be
a question
would anyone like to open councilor
Hinton thank you
thank you
that's probably my hearing I don't know
perhaps I've been listening to two
intently to watch what's been going on
here
the question I've got is what is it
about us investing in mid 5 million in
mid-suffic rather than two million but
I'm just here that or what's that all
about
yes certainly thank you
um so that is purely for cash flow
purposes so it's managing the cash of
each Authority and so if one if baber
has
um more cash and needs to invest it
overnight as we we often do because of
grants that have come in before they're
spent and similar situations then we're
increasing the amount that we could lend
to mid-suffic on a temporary basis
pending the need for baby to use that
cash
councilor Barrett I love that one it's
great isn't it
we're helping them out they've got the
better balance sheet but we've got the
money
Money Talks doesn't it
sorry just couldn't resist that one it
was just worth it getting it in
the question is I love having one over
Midsouth occasionally
that's not a question I suppose I could
frame it in a bit of that question they
are rather cocky about their position
and sort of make us feel like Cinderella
so it's quite nice so we can come out of
the cupboard can we come out the
cupboard
have we got any questions
I suspect that the reciprocals the same
as well that they can invest five
million us
but what you must promise is not to
mention
further questions
so no further questions so we'll now
move on to debate
and you'll have time to you'll be able
to speak for three minutes and speak
once and it will be timed would anyone
like to open the debate please
[Laughter]
foreign
if there's no one who wishes to open the
debate we'll move straight to the vote
so in that case I'll ask our corporate
manager governments and Civic office to
conduct the electronic food
you chair that is now in progress for
you to cast your vote
councilor beer
I think I might agree with you on this
one
was that four
that was four things
chair we have a unanimous vote that was
22 votes for
thank you so of course that is carried
now item 15 counselor appointments are
there any changes to placings
no changes to placings
and item 16 motions on notice let me see
none received so now we're drawing to
the end of the meeting I would just like
to draw your attention to the fact that
the next meeting is a Wednesday where
I'm switching it all around
um our next and last meeting of this
term is Wednesday the 22nd of March
at 5 30 but members are requested to
arrive half an hour earlier please could
you arrive at five o'clock on the 22nd
of March
so that we can take end of term
photographs so all in your best Bib and
Tucker and I look forward to seeing you
then for photographs and then the
meeting
thank you